Le reportage de Davide Gentile.!
- Même si elle garde le moral,
ur de Myreille est
très abîmé.
- C'est la pompe du coeur qui
- Novembre dernier, elle apprend
alve aortique doit être
changée et qu'une de ses artères
cardiaques est bou
Elle fait quatre allers-retoursr
passer des examens à l'Hôpital
Sacré-Coeur. 2000
de route en quelques semaines
pour finalement apprendre
qu'elle doit être opérée. GAUDRn
attente de chirurgie cardiaque
- Le dernier qui m'a ouvert
la bouche, là, puis qui m'a
voir le coeur, là...
Puis là, il y avait... icegardat
tout ce que... comment le coeur
fonctionnait. Ça, c'était
mon dernier examen.
il dit, ça va être bientôt,
votre opération." tait
au mois de décembre. On est
rendus au mois d'avril,ouvelles.
- Avec la sixième vague,
le réseau de la saaper le reapeé
en chirurgie. L'augmentation
du nombre d'employés infectés
par la COVID a ralenti
Entre le 19 mars et le 6 avril,
le taux d'activité des salles
baissé de 86 à 81 %.
Le délestage s'est accéléré dan.
Comme des milliers d'autres,
son mal en patience.
- Savez-vous ce que l'infirmier
m'a répondu? Ah, il dit :
on en a une pile, une pile, là,
il dit, de dossiers en attente.
Vous êtes dedans, là." Il dit :
baisser." Mais moi, quand est-ce
que je vais passer
- Difficile à dire, surtout
que le nombre de pte de chirurgt
passé de 156 000 à 159 000
depuis janvier.
Myreille pense qu'elle pass
après les plus jeunes, parce
qu'elle a maintenant 81 ans.
et plutôt pessimiste.
- Je pense pas de me rendre
à l'opération, co
là. Ils vont avoir ma peau.
Ça te tenterait pas
de le tenir?
- Ici Davide Genti